pour limiter la hausse des températures
à 1,5 degré celsius d'ici la fin du
siècle
il faut réussir à les réduire à 30 % nos
émissions de ges et atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici la fin 2050 le
giec sortir du nucléaire ne fera rien
pour le climat jean marc jancovici sans
le fossile l'industrialisation la
mondialisation et l'activité économique
ne pourront plus exister telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui
pablo services la croissance verte
s'accompagnera d'une augmentation d'une
croissance d'emplois alors là vous devez
vous demander pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous
envoie comme ça des phrases qui n'ont
pas forcément de contexte donc qu'ils
peuvent être biaisées
en fait tous les deux on a réalisé un
projet qu'on va vous décrire par la
suite et dans ce projet on était
confronté au problème de l'information
est donc en fait aujourd'hui on a envie
de vous faire vivre une partie de ce
projet de vous raconter certaines choses
et de vous faire comprendre comment
l'idéologie les idées qu'on a envie de
faire passer les convictions qu'on a
peuvent venir influencer un discours
dont bonjour à tous moi c'est les eaux
et bonjour moi c'est julien donc on est
deux étudiants ingénieurs donné comme
ingénieur technique l'un de ses tubes à
grenoble et on a décidé sur un année de
césure pour comprendre les enjeux
politiques géopolitiques sociaux liés à
l'énergie qu'on a fait six pays la
france l'australie la chine l'inde
himalayenne le maroc et l'islande
et dans chacun de ces pays là ont
rencontré deux chercheurs des
professeurs les sociologues pour parler
d'énergie alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'en fait nous dans notre école
on a un parcours très technique et que
donc on est excellent pour dimensionner
des éoliennes pour construire des
barrages et qu'en fait on sait pas à
quoi ça sert
dire que dans notre école on apprend à
faire ça mais on ne sait pas pourquoi on
le fait et donc comme le disait léo
notre projet nous a permis un peu de
mieux comprendre ça et en fait là on va
vous emmener visiter enfin revisité avec
nous trois
trois choses qu'on a vues et qui nous
ont particulièrement touché
et en fait la thématique générale dont
on va parler aujourd'hui ça va pas être
l'énergie ou le chemin thématique parce
qu'on n'a pas le temps d'en parler on va
parler d'esprit critique et
d'information car c était le point qui
nous a vraiment dérangé ou vraiment
perturbé durant ces six mois
en fait aujourd'hui dans une
problématique où l'information les
omniprésentes
c'est à dire que si jamais vous vous
intéressez un sujet et que vous tapez
sur google le sujet de hockey vous
intéressez vous allez trouver une
quantité d'informations qui est
faramineuse
le problème c'est pas de trouver de
l'information c'est de savoir si elle
est valable si elle est bonne et si elle
est exploitable
donc en fait aujourd'hui voilà notre
diapo qui n'est pas forcément le plus
beau résume un peu les sources
d'informations vous pouvez trouver mais
on voit à partir d'internet des
entreprises des de toutes les sources
d'information qui existe vous pouvez
recevoir l'information mais trouvait là
quelle est la bonne c'est pas quelque
chose d'évident
et donc là maintenant tous ensemble on
va aller à datong en chine pour voir la
ferme solaire en forme de poing dans nos
classes déjà une petite question comment
dsk dans la salle qui ont déjà vu cette
ferme solaire en termes de points de
lever la main juste pour voir un petit
peu pas mal pas mal c'est pas énorme
mais c'est pas mal mais du coup nous on
avait vu aussi avant de partir en projet
on avait dix voix génial ça a l'air
incroyable donc pour ceux qui
connaissent pas ces fermes solaires
donc c'est pas celle là parce que là
c'est une vue d'artiste donc ça
ressemble c'est un peu moins bon que ça
donc en forme de panda est dedans il ya
une école est le but de cette école
c'est sensibiliser les enfants et le
public aux enjeux liés à l'énergie
alors nous en tant qu'européens on a eu
la même information que ceux qui sont un
peu hanté là c'est donc à cette ferme
solaire si vous tapez sur google fermes
solaires en forme de panda vous allez
tomber sur une dizaine d'articles donc
là c'est la recherche google en gros
vous tombez vraiment sur dix articles
qui vont alors y en a plus on les a pas
tous faits on a fait pas mal déjà qu'ils
vont tous vous raconter la même chose
cette ferme solaire c'est super ça
permet de sensibiliser les locaux aux
problèmes environnementaux liés à la
production d'électricité
donc en gros là le solaire ça va être un
moyen d'éviter la pollution de l'air et
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
en même temps c'est un moyen donc voilà
de montrer que la chine fait des choses
dans le sens de la transition
énergétique
alors nous on est allé à datong on a
essayé d'aller visiter cette ferme
et là surprise on a mis plus de trois
jours avant de trouver quelqu'un qui
pouvait nous dire que cette ferme
exister et qu'on pouvait y aller donc
imaginer que cette ferme l'aslr elle
existe près de nous et je pense que vous
serez au courant
pour ceux qui vivent là pour ceux qui
vivent pas là
que vous soyez pas mais en gros si on
avait une ferme solaire comme ça en
france on en entendrait parler
hélas en chine on est frappé du fait que
les locaux n'avaient pas conscience de
son existence
donc une fois arrivés sur place on a
fait une interview en fait dans le
projet on faisait plein d'interviews et
donc là je suis en plein d'interviews on
dirait pas mais je suis en plein
d'interviews avec un chinois on a tous
un prénom on oublié désolé pour lui
et en fait là bas des chinois ils
parlent majoritairement que chinois un
tout petit peu anglais dans les grosses
villes et jamais français et nous on
parle français
un petit peu anglais on n'est pas très
bon et pas du tout chinois et du coup
heureusement les smartphones en fait
avec application chinoise on ne peut
traduire de français anglais à chinois
du coup là on est en pleine interview
est-ce qui est vachement intéressant
c'est qu'au début dans chaque interview
on a une méthode
au début on met à l'aise à personne en
demandant le cursus qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait et c
et puis après on ferme mesure une fois
qu'elle est à l'aise on attaque les
questions un peu perturbante sur
l'économie la politique et la arriver
aux questions un peu plus délicate
il se lève passe à coups de téléphone et
dit je suis ultra occupée il faut
s'imaginer on est en plein désert il est
tout seul avec son petit pote qui est là
et nous dit ultra occupée désolé vous
pouvez partir s'il vous plaît gentiment
donc là on sait clairement fait jeter en
fait et il s'avère qu'en chine c'est
particulièrement troublant l'accès à
l'information est très compliqué c'est à
dire que nous on n'a pas réussi en chine
à interviewer des gens qui s'y
connaissait dans les domaines sur
lesquels on s'intéressé on n'a pas
réussi à les rencontrer de façon à
comprendre des choses directement de
leur propre voie donc en fait
culturellement c'est très agréable ils
sont particulièrement accueillants par
contre structurellement les les
entreprises les associations tous à des
livres très peu d'informations donc en
fait non c'est vraiment confrontés au
fait que l'europe a reçu un message
vis-à-vis de sa ferme solaire qui ne
correspond pas du tout à la réalité du
terrain est donc là c'est une chance
pour nous d'avoir pu vérifier
directement la source de tous ces
articles qu'on a pu lire avant de partir
nous sommes expérience qu'il ya
vachement marquer aussi
c'est
nicolas hulot au ministère on a eu la
chance d'aller rencontrer nicolas hulot
pendant son mandat de ministre
donc là c'est une photo de nous juste
avant l'interview on est un peu stressé
on s'est fait une petite pause rigolade
avec des petites grimaces et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé derrière derrière à la
fin de chaque interview on demande à la
personne
on eût dit voilà on a monté la vidéo on
va la poster sur youtube si vous voulez
vous pouvez retirer des morceaux dans
l'interview qui vous dérange sent le
fake tout le monde et nicolas hulot et
son ministère ont été les seuls à
demander d'enlever différents passages
donc en fait aujourd'hui nous on va vous
montrer l'un de ses passages alors il
s'avère que le passage qu'on va vous
montrer aprilia pas de problème parce
que nicolas hulot des plus ministre donc
du coup ça pose des soucis à personne et
surtout en fait on va vous montrer
quelque chose qui n'est pas un complot
c'est à dire que là on peut dire ils
l'ont enlevée c'est vraiment qu'il ya un
gros problème derrière en fait vous
allez voir on va regarder ensemble
le but c'est pas de vous faire croire
qu'il existe des complots qu'on vous
cache forcément c'est plutôt de voir
quel passage a été enlevé et de
comprendre ensuite ensemble pourquoi
nous on pense que ce morceau a été
enlevé donc j'ai d'abord vous laisser
découvrir ce passage et puis après on en
discute en l'état des technologies
aujourd'hui si on voulait faire du 100%
éoliens ont bu très probablement sur
certains matériaux notamment ce qu'on
appelle les terres rares que l'on que
l'on trouve dans les turbines des
éoliennes
si on voulait faire du 100% solaire en
l'état des technologies aujourd'hui bien
que les paramètres bouge on buterait
peut-être et encore ça pour finir c'est
pas aussi sûr que ça sur
l'approvisionnement en termes de
silicium
il n'y a pas de système parfait donc
aujourd'hui les énergies renouvelables
si elles sont pas accompagnées d'une
baisse considérable de la consommation
ça ne suffira pas si elles sont pas
accompagnées aussi la possibilité de
recycler tout ça et notamment tout
l'utilisation des batteries si on rentre
pas dans une possibilité de réutiliser
ces batteries donc d'économie circulaire
le modèle quelque part provoquera
également ses effets a nui et ses effets
pervers
donc là on a bien vu à rien
d'extraordinaire on n'a rien appris
particulier en tout cas pour les
personnes qui s'intéressent un peu
l'énergie et transition énergétique
on se rend compte que ce qu'il raconte
on l'a facilement formation là et ce qui
est vraiment intéressant avec ça c'est
pourquoi
du coup nous a demandé de retirer
pourquoi le ministère nous demandent de
retirer une formation qui est déjà
présente partout alors là c'est une
autre interprétation on va vous la
donner on pense qu'aujourd'hui le
politique en tout cas en france sa
mission n'est pas nécessairement
d'informer forcément ça va être de
justifier des actions qui sont conduites
par le gouvernement et donc ici nicolas
hulot et radis il exprime quelque chose
qui traduit pas forcément la ligne
directive du gouvernement
en france aujourd'hui le renouvelable a
une image très positive le gouvernement
se positionne très souvent en faveur du
développement du renouvelable de la
filière renouvelable en france
hélas cette partie là elle pourrait
mettre en doute le fait que le
renouvelable c'est parfait et du coup ça
passe pas le la ligne directive est pas
respectée donc on préfère enlever un
morceau qui donnerait plus de cohérence
au message global parce que là ce qu'ils
disent est plein de bon sens quiconque
entend ça et s'intéresse harper au sujet
se dit effectivement le renouvelable
c'est pas parfait à 100 % il ya des
petits effets pervers induits
il ya des petits problèmes et si je veux
poser une solution au problème
climatique aux problèmes énergétiques
actuelles il faut que je prenne en
compte ces problèmes là mais la lui son
objectif à travers cette interview est à
travers le message que pour le
gouvernement c'est pas nécessairement de
donner toute la complexité du problème
en visio c'est de justifier l'action qui
est produit terre et nous autres c'est
un peu dommage donc un troisième exemple
de manipulations en tous cas de
manifestations de changement de donne et
c'est greenpeace
donc là avant de commencer on aime
beaucoup greenpeace ce qu'on va dire il
faut un combat qui était louable qui est
génial de sensibiliser le grand public
aux enjeux climatiques et aux enjeux
nucléaire par contre avec ça ils ont
vraiment abusé on va essayer de voir ça
ensemble
donc ils ont fait un tableau il ya
quelques mois qui comparer les
différentes sources d'énergie électrique
ok je suis père avec une colonne
émissions de co2 une colonne expérience
environnementale donc toutes les
conséquences sur l'eau et c est une
sorte de bilan en score sur cinq on
regarde ça avec julien et qu'est ce
qu'on voit on voit que le solaire
photovoltaïque il a plus plus en maison
de co2 ça veut dire qu'il va émettre
quasi pas de co2 par rapport aux autres
et le nucléaire ici et là plus moi ça
veut dire que le nucléaire il va émettre
a priori d'après ce tableau vers plus de
co2 que le solaire alors d'où quand on a
vu ça au début on s'est dit quand même
c'est étrange parce que nous depuis un
bon moment où on s'intéresse aux
différentes sources d'énergie et si on a
bien retenu quelque chose pour l'udc les
airs c'est que l'un de ces razzias
avantage c'est qu'il va émettre très peu
de co2 alors aujourd'hui en france s'ils
voulaient combattre le nucléaire vous
aurez pas de souci avec ça vous avez qu
à dire que ça produit des déchets qu'on
ne sait pas réellement traités il ya des
preuves de danger si jamais vous avez
une explosion de centrales ou quoi vous
allez avoir des grosses conséquences sur
l'environnement local
donc si vous avez envie de critiquer le
nucléaire aujourd'hui en france vous
avez pas besoin de venir inventer
quelque chose vis-à-vis du co2 alors
servent à justifier un petit peu en fait
quand on a vu ça on s'est dit on va
quand même aller regarder une autre
source pour regarder dans quelle mesure
éventuellement le nucléaire pourrait
émettre plus de co2 que le
photovoltaïque est donc condamnée sur le
site de l'ademe
l'ademe celle agence nationale qui
s'occupe de l'énergie en france et les
chiffres de l'ademe donc par rapport aux
émissions de co2 équivalent lampard le
co2 équivalent c'est cela c'est 55
grammes de co2 équivalent par
kilowattheure pour solaire
photovoltaïque et 10 grammes de co2
équivalent pour bartoli water attention
ici c'est une analyse de cycle de vie
ça veut dire qu'on prend en compte la
construction l'installation
l'utilisation est le démantèlement
et là on peut dire bah oui mais le dès
maintenant pour nucléaire on n'a jamais
fait comment on sait ce sont des
hypothèses c'est pour ça qu'un
incertitudes à 10% assumée par l'ademe
et même si on rajoute 10 % donc on
retire 10% le nucléaire il passe pas du
tout au dessus du sol air flow take donc
là pour conclure sur cet épisode de
notre investigation on a été déçu en
fait de se rendre compte que l'idéologie
prenait le pas sur la sur la rationalité
pardon donc en fait greenpeace
il aime pas nucléaire c'est un fait il
ya plein de raison de payer mais
nucléaire dont on n'est pas en train de
remettre ça en cause on n'est pas là
pour défendre ou pour soutenir le vin
pour soutenir ou pour attaquer nucléaire
c'est pas le débat aujourd'hui
par contre ça dommage que à travers leur
argumentaire il décide de construire des
nouveaux arguments qui sont en fait un
poison pour le débat c'est à dire que là
quand vous commencez à mettre dans le
débat l'idée que le nucléaire en termes
d'émissions de co2 c'est un problème
vous biaisé débat autour du nucléaire
est en fait quand des gens se rendre
compte de ce biais là ça va vraiment
décrédibiliser le travail de greenpeace
derrière donc on trouve ça vraiment
dommage en fait il ya ce genre de
procédé qu'il soit mis en place par des
associations qui n'auraient pas besoin
de ça pour continuer à mener leur combat
et en fait ça c'est valable pour qu'une
piste convient de parler mais aussi pour
le ministère avec nicolas hulot ou même
avant avec les chinois en fait
aujourd'hui on est face à une crise
climatique et énergétique je pense qu'on
a tous conscience qui est terrible et on
est a priori assez jeune dans la salle
j'ai l'impression on risque de le vivre
ça tous ensemble et si on trouve pas une
solution assez rapidement pour répondre
à ce problème là bas ont regardé grosse
gros gros soucis et du coup font se
mettre ensemble collectivement réfléchir
et pour cela si chaque acteur vient avec
sa petite information qui est un peu
biaisé et l'assument pas et savent
étirer le ton envers lui le débat sera
rien en fait
et c'est ça qu'on aime qu'on critique
vraiment nous c'est le fait que tous les
acteurs malheureusement aujourd'hui ont
des intérêts dans son climatique aidant
sociaux énergétique mais pour ses
intérêts là ils vont changer un peu et
donner ou les utiliser de manière
biaisée donc enfin pourquoi conclure un
peu sur ce qu'on vient de vous dire là
déjà une première chose c'est que ce
qu'on vous a raconté durance tedx ça
c'est un moussa s'est appliqué au
contexte de l'énergie parce que nous on
s'est intéressé à ce sujet là comme on
disait au début mais ça peut s'étendre à
tous les domaines c'est à dire que si
vous travaillez dans le domaine de
justice dans le domaine de la santé en
fait n'importe quel domaine
cette information aux multiples elle
existe c'est à dire que les trois
exemples que vous a montré là vous
pourrez retrouver le même type d'exemple
dans plein d'autres domaines
donc en fait déjà ça se réduit pas
l'énergie est ensuite la deuxième chose
qu'on aimerait vraiment sur laquelle on
aimerait vraiment insisté ce soir cet
aprem plus tôt on a vu ce qu'il s'est
vraiment sur le fait que l'énergie
enfin l'information pardon elle peut
avoir multiples facettes et quand vous
entendez un discours donné ce qui est
intéressant c'est pas forcément le fait
que le discours soit parfaitement juste
parce qu'il va toujours être biaisé
d'une certaine façon vraiment ce qui est
essentiel c'est d'avoir conscience des
différents billets qui ont construit ce
discours et de pourra dire d'accord ce
discours je n'ai compris et j'ai compris
qu'elles étaient les biais qui ont
permis de construire un exemple sur nous
quelles ont été les conséquences ce
projet sur notre vie à nous en fait
quand on est parti en est ces mesures on
est des retours d'expérience comme vous
ce moment avec les anciens qu'il parte
qu'elle revienne en mode c'est génial de
faire une césure aller dans tous les
pays vous allez voir prenez l'avion
c'est royal et du coup nous ce projet là
là c'est 27 tonnes de co2 on a pris
l'avion partout partout ces pays là on a
émis à 2 27 tonnes de co2 que pour le
déplacement
c'est l'équivalent de cinq français sur
un an mais tous cumulés donc c'est
énorme et ça en fait on n'a pas entendu
parler quand elle a voulu par ce projet
la personne n'a dit attention il ya
l'avion qui émet du co2 manière
drastique et du coup aujourd'hui en tant
qu'individu on a choisi de plus prendre
l'avion lobby pour éviter d'avoir ces ce
bilan carbone désastreux
il ya d'autres manières de faire soit on
a pu prendre plus de temps le faire
enlever l'eau et cetera soit allé moins
loin peut-être juste vers l'europe où le
maroc les pays la méditerranée il ya
différentes manières mais c'est des
choix et non à l'époque on n'est pas
connaissance de toutes les informations
et du coup notre choix était biaisé
parce qu'on n'est pas toutes les infos
pour synthétiser ce que vient de dire
les eaux en fait s'informer c'est aussi
se donner la possibilité de faire des
choix qui sont en accord avec ce qu'on
pense vraiment essentiel pour nous dire
que nous quand on est parti on avait en
tête on est écologiste entre guinée en
fait personne n'est réellement c'est un
débat autres mais plus d'autres façons
de
nous de percevoir le monde c'était
prendre l'avion c'est pas si grave en
fait si concrètement c'est un vrai
problème et on aurait dû le savoir à
l'époque on ne savait pas on s'est
informée on a fini par le savoir et on
sait pas flageller pendant des heures
pour se faire pardonner de ça on a pris
la décision du coup de ne plus prendre
du coup pour conclure remettez en
question tout le temps quand vous êtes
mal d'infos même remettez-nous en
question là on vient de parler pendant
18 minutes environ si ça trouve il ya eu
des billets il m'a sûrement lui-même
d'information et du coup faut tout le
temps être vigilant dès qu'on a un
discours découvert une information la
remettre en question se demander
pourquoi il dit ça à tel moment
pourquoi est elle source si à la fin
vous venez nous voir en nous disant ce
passage là j'aurais préféré qu'on parle
plus un peu plus de ça ou alors qu'on
précise cette chose là parce que sinon
ça me paraît un complet nous ça nous
fera super plaisir vraiment hésité pas à
critiquer ce qu'on a fait la critique
peut être très constructive et du coup
merci beaucoup pour votre attention
c'était un plaisir de parler et passer
une très bonne après midi
[Applaudissements]